ليله صعبه اخرى في جنين القوات
الاسرائيليه تقتحمت المدينه الاعتقال عدد
من المطاردين ولكن قبل ان تصل اليهم كانت
قد قتلت عددا من الشبان احدهم كان في
طريقه الى عمله وفق شهود عيان
كانت اطلاق النار
مشاهد الوداع هذه تكررت في جنين 58 مره
منذ بدايه العام المدينه التي اتسمت بشكل
المسلح للمقاومه دفعت النصيب الاكبر من
الضحايا حيث تؤكد الاحصاءات ان هذا العام
كان الاكثر دمويه على الفلسطينيين منذ
العام 2006
[موسيقى]
وتتضرع اسرائيل في عملياتها داخل المدن
الفلسطينيه بانها تلاحق مطلوبين ومنفذين
محتملين لعمليات ضد اهداف لها في الضفه
والداخل
مواكب التشييع المتواصله سواء في جنين او
هنا في رام الله وغيرها من المدن
الفلسطينيه تصب زيت الغضب على نار التصعيد
دون ان تستبعد اسرائيل ان يكون الانفجار
هناك في الجنوب مع قطع غزه من بلده سلواد
عبد الحفيظ جوان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه